hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons why the
Jeffrey Epstein case inspires so many
conspiracy theories Anna north at Fox
comm the question folks is if you tried
could you be this stupid if you put
effort into it if you dedicated yourself
if you trained your mind could you be
this daft to write an article that is
basically pondering why the Jeffrey
Epstein case inspires so many conspiracy
theories why why why so many unanswered
questions it's a relatively simple thing
a man who was running an international
human trafficking ring who was close
friends with politicians the CEOs of
major corporations prime ministers a man
who had been convicted of molesting
underage girls and given a sweetheart
deal because and I quote Alexander
Acosta Trump's labor secretary said he
quote belonged to intelligence was given
a sweetheart deal where he served around
a year in like a minimum security
federal prison and left everyday to go
to work
and part of that deal is that he
wouldn't have to inform on his
co-conspirators that man who was then
reah Rus today few months ago supposedly
cooperating with prosecutors charged
several counts of sex trafficking was
going to go to trial and potentially
inform on his co-conspirators because
there was no get-out-of-jail-free card
this time a man who tried to kill
himself
a few weeks ago in one of the most
secure detention centers in America the
Metropolitan Correctional Facility where
they held El Chapo where they've held
terrorists I think Zacharias Masseria
could be wrong that guy who was on
suicide watch was taken off suicide
watch his roommate was moved out of his
room and a few hours later he hung
himself in said facility and now there
will be no trial and there will be no
open court why would a case like that
all these internet loonies all these
tinfoil hat wearing conspiracy theorists
seize redditors these these marginalized
creatures that just have to make
everything into one big [ __ ]
conspiracy why would this set wanna set
them off
you better be asking the question why
perfectly rational reasonable people who
had been asleep who had been [ __ ]
asleep and I mean asleep watching The
Bachelor asleep are starting to wake up
now and they're starting to go ahh like
they might not be full-on you know
they're not storming area 51
but they're even going you know what
wait a minute something's wrong here and
just laying Maxwell I just ripped off a
part of my nail and that my finger is
bleeding just lame Maxwell that's how I
don't cut my nails I just I tear them
off anxiously and that's how I think
many of you should do it right I believe
in different ways that anxiety should
leave the
one of them is to tear off your nails um
and and what will happen is you know
when you're done winning you're bleeding
that's when you know you're done when is
my nail short enough when there's a pool
of blood on your finger and then your
nail hurts for the next couple of days
and you go to grab something your nail
will hurt because it's just raw skin and
then the nail grows back that is how to
do it we're gonna go in a just lay max
while eating it in an out burger because
we're living either in a simulation
that's glitching or this is either a
PSYOP with it basically like we can do
whatever we want now it doesn't have to
make sense and we're gonna distract you
because now it's becoming this weird
tabloid thing I'm like oh Epstein's
gal-pal
the [ __ ] was [ __ ] trafficking kids
and they're calling it like Epstein's
gal-pal seen eating it in and out but
gal-pal what eats his [ __ ] taking 13
14 year-old kids to an island to [ __ ]
Bill Richardson that fat [ __ ]
there was a governor in New Mexico and
you treating this like it's some like
fun tabloid scandal this is the darkest
[ __ ] humanly possible and the press is
turning into like some tabloid fodder
where was just Lane spotted was she
eating it in and out burger did she get
animal style why is she walking around
free well nobody asking her questions
she's reading a book about the deaths of
CIA agents and a [ __ ] in and out it's
to Ventura or Studio City or whatever
location Jaime Vernon told me where it
was I forgot Universal City yeah what
the [ __ ] is happening there was an
article that said she was uh she was
holed up with some tech guy in
Manchester by the sea that town that's
weird too she's in a movie she's in
Manchester by the sea she's in some big
and if you have any problem folks I have
a Ricola because I think I'm coming down
with something I'm trying not to smoke I
probably will smoke for the end of the
show
I don't smoke other than doing this
podcast
I really do not smoke unless I do the
podcast but there's something about the
nicotine and the smoking that you know I
mean I've done good podcasts and and not
smoke there's something about the
nicotine and the cigarette that feels it
lends itself to conversation and any of
you that listen to show maybe that are
younger they vape skies do not lend
themselves to conversation the way
cigarettes do because there's no pausing
there's no inhaling actually I mean I
know there's inhaling exhaling but it
doesn't feel the same way there's no
give-and-take and it just shows that the
generation coming up now a generation
that has been you know raised primarily
online a generation full of you know
adderall and anxiety uh you're not
you're not learning how to really
conversate in the appropriate way you
just select Ben see what he does he just
sucks on that every 30 seconds he
doesn't know how to speak to anyone
because he doesn't know it's not his
fault he doesn't know he doesn't
understand how to talk when you talk to
him he will stare off into the sky and
leave because he doesn't know this whole
generation of people has never been
taught how to communicate a big part of
learning how to communicate is to smoke
cigarettes
so it's really what it is you know I
mean I don't I could sugarcoat it um can
you do it without smoking cigarettes no
now I will say this she got max well
they said she's at Manchester by the
city then they track the guy down of
course the government it's old and you
are opposed to this the government is no
interest okay they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care they don't care at all
where she is you know so the New York
Post finds her uh throwing down a
double-double or whatever at the
universal [ __ ] in and out reading a
book about the death
of CIA agents I mean and then there's a
review that's supposedly attributed to
her I'm gonna read you guys the review
you gotta realize you gotta realize
where we are and take stock of this
because it's [ __ ] insane and then I'm
gonna tell you after this I'll tell you
why I think I'm banned from the your
mom's house Network um I believe I am
bad I don't know that is not a fact but
I believe after today I am banned from
the your mom's house Network I don't
know I do not want to be banned I am NOT
asking to be bad I feel is that I am bad
after the events of today I will go into
why well go into why that's my own
little scandal we have asked and a lot
of hands here folks we've got a scandal
on our hand it's not as big as Epstein
there's not as many powerful people
involved there are some not nearly as
powerful but we do have a scandal G
Maxwell gave five stars to this book I
don't have the name of the book but you
can easily find it supposedly sales for
this book shot way the [ __ ] up okay
everybody's like what is she reading
what is what is the madam reading what
is the madam reading it's a great way to
sell your book if a child pimp is seen
reading your book many people in this
country go yup that's what we want
she had a harem of child [ __ ] let's
buy this book she's laying Maxwell it
gives it five stars goes a good friend
of mine died recently under very tragic
circumstances some of us saw it coming
for quite a while but it was still a
huge shock when it finally happened I
picked up this book at the advice of a
friend and absolutely couldn't put it
down
I'd read it while walking the dog
getting fast food or even just lounging
around the house it helped me realize
that my friend really believed in
something and they given your life of
the CIA NSA FBI Mossad or
other intelligence agencies truly a
higher calling and not something to
mourn a wholehearted recommendation
supposedly from G Maxwell she's
reviewing a think of this folks think of
this a woman who participated in the
horrific abuse of children who knew damn
well why it was going on is reading a
book about the deaths of intelligence
operatives of which Jeffrey Epstein
certainly was one she probably is one
she's pretty probably foreshadowing and
she's probably not gonna be around
forever although there's a reason she's
still here and she's still doing [ __ ]
like that I mean we're in Sam Tripoli
always used to talk about this chaos
theory of like things not having to make
sense and the idea of just this overload
of information a lot of a disinformation
it's hard to look at the events of the
last week and I think you'd have to come
to grips with the very small group of
powerful people that have had power had
almost absolute in total power for a
very long time we're starting to lose it
it's starting to come under all these
things are starting to come undone and
it's like the 11th hour and they're
getting very sloppy and they had to get
rid of this guy there was no way he
could be an open court and now this
[ __ ] is eating cheeseburgers and
reviewing spy novels in LA and it's like
at a certain point you like this bit is
she rogue he's someone instructed her to
do this is this part of the plan do they
want people to think he was intelligence
you you you'd you'd think not because he
clearly was but is there some benefit to
them
if it sounds so crazy that people
dismiss it because maybe it's a step too
far for people to believe that this is
an activity to sponsor my elements of
our government is easier for people to
believe that rich people just have
deviant sexual appetites and Epstein was
there to satisfy those appetites driving
them to the idea that he was in the
intelligence community does it does it
make it this shadowy thing that people
have a much harder time believing and it
gets too complex and people ultimately
check out I don't know I'm very
interested and why these things are
happening or have they lost control the
operation is it like a play that the
director sits in the back end with his
head in his hands goes [ __ ] god I hope
we make it to act 3 is that what where
we're at now does anyone think about
this is everyone just watching the bat
wires everyone watching the bait is it
that good should I start watching it
it's not good it's not good
why the entire country is under the
spell of The Bachelor people have
careers because just like they talk
about the bat what is going on is this
not more interesting to you then the
bachelor I don't understand
rich cuts wanna [ __ ] a rich guy or
selfish gods that aren't rich whatever
and I've got poor either have teeth
isn't that simple don't you get it the
relationships aren't real is it this
stuff better am I wrong
maybe I'm wrong Epstein hung himself his
[ __ ] is eaten in and out this was
Chelsea Clinton's best friend
this woman was friends with the cleanse
hab he's got a [ __ ] painting of our
president in heels in drag in his
mansion in New York City which was
outfitted with two-way mirrors and
recording equipment for blackmail and
everybody still just wants to talk about
the bachelor folks what would need to
happen I need to understand this person
I'm not against love I'm not against
dating shows I'm not against people
having fun I'm not against meaningless
horseshit I trafficking a lot of it it's
why I do for a living
I had a five-minute bit about ice cream
I understand frivolous activity but how
good is this goddamn sure I'm scared to
watch The Bachelor cuz I think I'm just
gonna end up babbling about The Bachelor
for the rest of my life because I'm
looking around going this shit's pretty
interesting but there are people that
are offended if you ask them to like
what your opinion is they're like well I
don't really know but yeah I don't I
don't know about that
that's not my beat I do Bachelor what
people just love I get I mean I I I
don't know I don't offend any of you in
my audience that maybe like The Bachelor
I'm sure it's a fun show but does it not
interest anyone that there's clearly a
glitch in the [ __ ] matrix and we're
all watching this in real [ __ ] time I
have a lot of respect for the your mom's
house Network I think it's a great
network I think Tom and Christina are
very funny dr. Drew who's also on the
network he's very talented at what he
does and I've never listened to his show
but I like Celebrity Rehab and I enjoyed
Loveline with Adam Carolla and dr. Dre
they're good people and that's fine I
want to preface this by saying my first
instinct is always to lie and it is
always the right instinct for the most
part lying shows that you've taken a
time to think about what's happening and
that you care about what's happening
telling the truth is like not wearing
deodorant it's inconsiderate and it
means that you don't care it means you
don't have any regimen you haven't
thought about anything you've kind of
just rolled out of bed
that's why truth when you're honest with
somebody there's a premium to that it's
usually with somebody you really like
a friend somebody you're [ __ ] it
there's a premium to honesty because
it's rare honesty is not something that
happens all the time for good reason
people just don't walk around being
honest with each other the world would
be an utter chaos if everybody told
everybody what they thought of each
other it would be an utter cat people
have to be kept in the dark they have to
be lied to and manipulated this is why
we have what we have with the Epstein
and the da da da okay I'm just saying
how it is
I'm not saying how it should be I'm not
moralizing I'm telling you what it is
people keep secrets no conspiracies
aren't real cuz no one can keep seeing
you're keepin secrets right now from
your wife and you're telling me that no
one can keep secrets you're keeping
secrets of somebody asleep next to
secrets get kept for [ __ ] years
people have secret families they never
talk about there's good lawyers out
there you know this says nobody can keep
secrets bad Liars bad Liars can never
believe in conspiracies because they
don't know how to [ __ ] lie they don't
know how to create create and craft a
narrative lies you can't just [ __ ]
around with a lie here and there you got
to be constantly lying all the time you
got to create a world and populate it
with untruths big lies require little
eyes to sustain them that's a famous
quote I don't know who said it that's
what needs to happen pathological liars
lie all the time because they want to be
good at it if you're drunk if you drink
and drive every night statistically
you're going to be better at it am i
telling you to do it no I'm telling you
what it is if you drink a drive once a
month you're gonna be all nervous same
with driving high same with lying same
with [ __ ] same with stand-up comedy
you got to do it a lot okay so my first
instinct in many situations is to spin a
yarn a fable a lie an untruth because I
care about the person on the other end I
realize that I've done the wrong thing
and rather than admit it like a crazy
person I lie to cover it up because I
realize I was wrong you're lying because
you realize you're
wrong if anyone calls you what Ally say
I'm lying to you because I know that I'm
wrong and I love you being honest with
you would be insane am i insane are you
insane honesty is not the best policy no
one says that you know who says that
schoolteachers cuz they talked to
children all day because they have
childlike minds we don't need any advice
that's on a guidance counselors wall
it's not going to help
don't hit me about no Walter no lie
even after today I will still lie
I'm only upset at the fact that my lie
was not good never lie quick take a
minute take a breath today big Jays
girlfriend Christine Evans who I like
but you know we'll get into that you
know you know these people you know I
just you know I join her but and she's
in town she grew up in Redondo Beach uh
and she goes hey I want to show you
where I grew up we'll go to the beach
take a little swim we'll get it's a
seafood and a seafood Shack I'm in I
like swimming in the ocean
I'm in there we did we had a beautiful
lunch but a half-hour lunch about a 45
minute dip in the Pacific Ocean and to
do all that round trip in a car about
five and a half hours in the car about
five and a half in the guard I could
have driven I could have flown to New
York City for the amount of time it took
me to get my fat ass in the Pacific for
forty five [ __ ] minutes but it was a
lovely dip and I like that it's just
it's it's a lot traveling around LA is a
lot she tells me all what you want to
put on some music so I put on some music
i put on Toby Keith oh and God love her
it's a great song God love her she was
born in a Mississippian Mont I don't
know the [ __ ] lyrics her dad it
wanted to be with me and I said you know
who cares it's catchy
it was unshut phul I put it on she's
like oh you have the worst dates music
and of all my friends I'm like [ __ ]
Toby keeps you talking all day Matt how
she wanted to buy all the houses in
Manhattan Beach she's like I want to buy
these houses I keep telling Jay for
millions not a lot of money we're an
entertainment for men [ __ ] Toby Keith
could buy ten of those houses and you're
running your mouth I said that too and a
car go Toby Keith why ten of these
houses
you'll die in this rental you don't have
to agree with Toby you don't that think
he's good
it's a catchy goddamn song God love her
so we get down there we have a nice of a
nice lunch I do this Instagram story
where I'm on the beach and we go up this
beautiful peak in Redondo we're looking
out at the ocean it's got a great view
when I say hey I write on Instagram I
say hey cuz these are he said you will
see things that are similar to this you
know six months ago I was living in the
middle of a busy highway but I started
reading listening to Gary Vaynerchuk and
he's the teachings of Gary van your
truck and now I realized when I heard
him that I had to stop losing and I had
to start winning and now we just broke
ground on will it be a 25 million dollar
state and how did I pay for it I paid
for it with gratitude and then you know
hashtag hustle grind
it's a funny post and it clearly shows
that I'm in Redondo Beach the beautiful
then she goes there's a Trump golf
course it's open to the public you want
to go check that out I'm like oh yeah I
think it's fun go see what kinds of
people are still going to trump things
who don't give a [ __ ] I kind of like
that you know and it's just a bunch of
white dudes and dads and they're all
playing golf and you know me and her
walk in and you know they're not
thrilled but she's like it's open to the
public and I felt like explaining to her
honey not our public see the Palos
Verdes public is differ
than our public our public is public bus
it's not open to us okay I guarantee you
I'm wearing a bathing suit and you're
wearing a sarong you bought on the
Venice Boardwalk from somebody with a
heroin needle hanging out of their chin
so that's not the public that they are
really interested in walking through
their doors okay but I didn't buy the
way that I mean Venice it's like you go
down there the best things there are the
bodybuilders with AIDS Muscle Beach all
the bodybuilders with AIDS is like
beating aids they all have AIDS and
they've beaten AIDS
they're so built they no longer have
AIDS or penises their penises have gone
away because they've just pumped so much
iron and they've all beaten AIDS but I
didn't see them today because the
outdoor gym was being remodeled sadly so
we go to the Trump course she goes into
the bathroom to change your clothes like
a true crackhead
okay she's like well she has some fake
question about the restaurant you think
what is the restaurant open where's the
restroom I'm like they know what you're
in here for they know you just want to
go in there deliver a baby and leave it
in the toilet
so just go do that and I'll go take a
[ __ ] and then we'll leave okay we don't
have to pretend that we're here to talk
to the event planner about throwing a
wedding okay they know you just want to
abandon a baby in the bathroom so almond
do you ever see somebody when you like
walk into a nice place and you start
telling the tale about while you're
there and the people like we know what
this is just [ __ ] we're letting you do
it just use the restroom you don't have
to it wins t top just use the just go
throw up you're withdrawing right you're
withdrawing and you you need to throw
before you get some suboxone okay just
go do that don't [ __ ] tell us that
yeah you're here to plan your daughter's
wedding so I I remember I don't remember
I get an email from the book of the your
mom's house Network email was 408 said
hey Tim I hope you're finding your way
here
hope you're having no trouble finding
the place text me well I experience a
range of emotions in the Trump bathroom
and Palos Verdes I was like [ __ ] I was
supposed to do dr. drew today at 4:00
[ __ ] it is now 458 that email was sent
to me at four away I'm in the Trump
bathroom
I did what I never used to do I used to
call out sick from work all the time but
I never did the no call no show which is
what I did now now here's when you do
the no call no show you have to stay off
the grid and you have to not fire back
you need to get your story straight you
need to sit on it for a minute and think
because you've done the no call no show
the only ways to go harder into the
light disappear off the grid sink deeper
into the hole take a minute think about
it go what can I do here
you know go grab an old photo of you in
New York throw that on Instagram go dark
for two days email the dude say you had
to go be in New York who knows all these
things but I panicked I was
panic-stricken I'm so ashamed I was
panic-stricken on the toilet in the
Trump golf course open to the public
Palos Verdes beautiful I was sitting on
the toilet reading the email on the
turlet and I said [ __ ] I email back
immediately I had an emergency I cannot
make it it by the way it's a [ __ ]
hour after I was supposed to be there I
two seconds later I apologize I walk out
I'd call Ben and then it hits me I
uploaded an Instagram story from the
beach a half hour ago when I should have
been doing the show I have a photo up
from the [ __ ] beach which is the
opposite of an emergency it is literally
the opposite of an emergency
I am frolicking on the beach and I
didn't show up for this [ __ ] show and
then I lied to the guy and it was such a
poorly conceived lie like it was shut
and now I'm ashamed not because I lied
because I didn't put the time in the
care into a good lie nothing makes you
feel better than pulling off a good lie
and I didn't do it and I pride myself on
being able to do it and I was just and
the thing that saves me is it's so funny
that there's something there there's
something I was so funny that I couldn't
stop laughing because it's so utterly
disrespectful it's so utterly
disrespectful it's [ __ ] amateur hour
it's it's Giselle just lame sorry it's
just laying eating in and out reading
spy novels it's choking epstein out in
his cell and then [ __ ] like it's all
that [ __ ] on a very small level it's
it's I'm doing to the Booker that
Network what our government is doing us
basically going oh [ __ ] you and I hope
you like it I hope you like it because
it is what it is and here's a photo of
me with my [ __ ] fat ass frolicking on
the beach and I had an emergency and I
can't make it I email you an hour after
I was supposed to be there so I would
imagine at this point
I would not be shocked there's a lot of
opportunities and you go why didn't I
get that opportunity there's a lot of
opportunity here's the silver lining to
this I will not wonder if I'm never on
any of their shows I won't lie oh it
won't keep me awake at night like I
might forget this and think for a minute
I wonder why and then I'll go oh yeah oh
yeah yeah there was that time I know
called no-showed for dr. drew after dark
and then shot often amateur hour email
from the turlet of the Trump and then
right on the Instagram story it's like
it's not only like I'm lying to you it's
really like I should it would have
almost be better if I'd emailed them
back hey [ __ ] you
that would have almost been better if I
went hey how about [ __ ] you cuz that's
what it is saying you at an emergency
and then having the Instagram story of
you at the beach is two words it is [ __ ]
you it is that I didn't even take the
time to lie good about this I just
thought I would [ __ ] throw it out
there so if you message me some of you
message me to go you should do your
mom's house and I go yeah yeah I'd love
to do that show they're great you don't
have to message that anymore
I'd still like to do it but if I don't
do it this one is 100% on me
this is my fault this is a bad move
[ __ ] Thank You Christine Evans
ruining my [ __ ] life monday dot-com
folks the last ad I did here I said I
didn't know what the company was cuz I'm
a comedian and that's a joke I clearly
do you know what the company does I'm a
comedian as a comic you know I make
jokes but
it's a good service if you have a
business out there many of you do not
have a business many of you shouldn't
have a business you should not try to
have a business it will not work many of
you know your own limitations and you
live within the parameters that you've
created for yourself in your own mind
many people tell you that those things
are not true I think good but some of
you are out there trying to create
something and some of you are creative
your your business minded you can do it
you should be your own boss you should
be independent you should not be filing
into an office like some drone you know
I'm making small talk about The Bachelor
while you sit at a soul-crushing
job that doesn't care about you you
should do something on your own that's
what I'm doing I find it very fulfilling
most times and the great thing about
Monday comm okay is it as easy to stay
organized if you're starting your own
business
easy to find files looking through your
emails to find stuff is a nightmare I
hate doing that I have 2,000 emails
right now that are unread Monday comm
will organize everything in one place
you aren't wasting your time searching
for the things you need it creates
accountability okay what's more annoying
than asking someone to do something and
never getting a response well I guess if
your kid had cancer and you didn't have
money and you couldn't get them the care
that they wanted that but other than
that what would be more annoying than
asking someone to do something and never
getting a response here's something that
might be annoying if an a guy that was
running an international child
trafficking ring was about to testify
against prominent members of the
government and was found dead in his
cell and no one seemed to care but other
than that other than the kid with cancer
and other than Jeffrey Epstein what else
would be annoying asking somebody if
they did something and not getting
response are they working on it did they
never get the email did you never get
the email Donna are you just gonna say
that are you gonna literally look at me
and say that you never got the email you
fat slob that
you gonna look at me right now in my
face my bloated Irish face and tell me
that you didn't get this done I told you
to do it
god damn it Donna what I hired you I
knew there'd be a problem but you're
friends of my brother he's a goddamn
loser
and I knew what I brought you in it
would be more the same so to avoid this
you get Monday calm this platform is
suitable for any sized team from two
freelancers working together me and Ben
to thousands collaborating across the
globe Goldman Sachs or the app scene
paedophile Network how grab bet Jeffrey
FC would not have been caught if he used
Monday comm if Jeffrey I've seen used
Monday comm he would not be dead in his
jail cell he'd be on his island live in
life because he'd be easily able to
track emails and demand accountability
from his staff his lane wouldn't be
eaten in an out burger
she'd be responding to emails gotta
check out Monday calm it is really good
listen it's what we're starting to use
it now it's a workplace management tool
we are now coordinating all of our
things the podcasts the videos my live
dates the website we're revving up we're
ramping up more people are liking what
we're doing we gotta get ready for it
it's easy to joke around because that's
what I do it's my job you see so it's
easy to joke around but one thing is not
funny what's not funny is being a
[ __ ] failure and many of you will be
a failure if you don't figure out a way
to organize your business okay
so instead of email spreadsheets random
files whiteboards to-do lists post-it
notes Monday that come organizes and
tracks everything in one place okay
that's why I'm recommending Monday comm
and if you got a Monday that come slash
Jim they're gonna give you a free 14-day
trial no commitment you could check out
Monday night comment see for yourself
how helpful their software is Monday
comm slash Tim there's no reason to not
sign up for a 14-day trial if you're a
struggling artist if you're comedian if
if you start if you have the band if you
are running an online business if you're
in sales or marketing to any degree if
you have clients if your people you want
to keep track of stuff if you have
ingoing and outgoing emails if you have
conference calls and meetings with
people organize your [ __ ] man there
there's there's a reason that you don't
have the things that you want and it
often is because you're not organized or
gonna do it if I was organized I would
be so [ __ ] I wouldn't know anyone I know
right now I would not know anyone I know
this is the truth I'm gonna be honest
with you I was working if I taped every
set I wouldn't live where I live I
wouldn't have any of the friends I have
if I just taped every [ __ ] Sat put
him in a database like Monday comm could
easily organize for me and I followed up
and I and I and I punched up the jokes
and the tags and I did everything I
would not know and I wouldn't know my
family I wouldn't know anyone I would
just be somewhere I don't know where I'd
be but it would be a hell of a lot
better than where I am and then my lack
of organization is literally the worst
thing about me I'm a hard worker and I
have some talent but I'm not organized
that's why I [ __ ] missed it dr. Drew
thing so I'm not [ __ ] organ it's a
perfect example of Monday comm if I had
a reminder Bing you gotta be today 4
p.m. at dr. Drew I wouldn't have to lie
and embarrass myself and now probably
now banned from your mom's house so the
network not your mom's house I'm welcome
there any time
Wawa Monday dot-com slash Tim get a free
14-day trial thank you goodbye I love
what people taking a tour their hometown
like you give a [ __ ] that's the place we
you said drink in high school shut up
who gives a [ __ ]
tell me about real estate prices tell me
what's going on I don't care
your first boyfriend took you to this
cliff who gives a [ __ ]
unless it's interesting at least what I
take people around my hometown I'm like
that's where we did coke at 13 that's
where my parents marriage finally fell
apart
that's where I saw this they had a Latin
Kings or one of the higher-ups get his
head hit with a 40 because they came in
and started trouble you know but you
know there's nothing worse than that
basic [ __ ] tour of life and this is
where you got the best pizza throw my
career away today cuz I'm [ __ ]
listening to where you used to get pizza
my whole [ __ ] now I'm [ __ ]
one of the biggest podcast in the
country I can't go on it cuz I'm [ __ ]
taking a tour of Redondo Beach while she
tells me all these estates she's gonna
own yeah you're gonna have an estate
people are out of the bird it's 4
million that's not a lot of money is it
not well then can you lend it to me I
understand these people that are like
think big I get all of that think small
folks think small I do get the idea of
why it's attractive to people to believe
in and the endless and endless
possibilities I get that I think an
element of that is very important but I
don't think you can OD on that delusion
is a drug you kind of need a little bit
of it but you can overdose on it you
know comics that have OD Don delusion
you can see it they're kind of they kind
of look like they have wet frame like
hey man what's going on hey man date you
can feel it you go oh you stuck the
needle deep in you mainlined
delusion and now you're in your mid-30s
and you look Haggard and things are not
good and you're bombing in a bar for 11
people and and you're talking to me
about Netflix
that what come again but you can you all
know those people that have just a deed
you got so you got it just every now and
then alittle delusions good I don't
think Christina's od'd on delusion but I
she's realistic she's she's good person
you know I like her we can all do it we
can all D sometimes you got to rein it
in you got to rein your friends in
sometimes you start thinking you're
gonna be able to do all these things and
you're like let me just focus on one
[ __ ] thing don't focus on the house
that you're gonna buy when you do the
thing focus on the thing and then don't
worry about the [ __ ] house it's all
backwards you're got it backwards I just
want a house on a cliff yeah you know
what everyone does everyone does
dum dum everybody that has ever lived
wants that you are not unique in that I
just want a beautiful seaside mansion so
all I want you to get course you do we
all do what can you do that other people
can't what is the thing that separates
you from all the other people that want
that is it the work ethic is it the
ingenuity is it the tenacity what is it
but you know my dreams now
how'd you want to own a house I don't
even care where it is or what it looks
like I just want a home that's what I
want I don't care if I don't care
anymore I've been beaten down so much
that my dreams are like what people my
my dreams are people's like safety
people like well if everything goes to
[ __ ] we can live like this that's my
dream that's my like best-case situation
I hear people's conversations like we're
[ __ ]
we can always buy a half a million
dollar house and just
I'm like you that's what I think I mean
so you just can't main light you just
can't mainline the delusion folks you
need a little bit of it and then you'll
meet people with no delusion and that's
a problem too because they don't believe
in anything you don't believe in they
get and you meet these people that are
so married to their own unfortunate
circumstances I went out the other day
with some kid and it was just it was
just he was around and I went to this
costume shop with them nice kid wasn't a
date wasn't any of that younger guy I
don't I say kid I don't mean like
Epstein kid young early 20s going out
platonic friend thing we go to the
steakhouse Musso and Frank's out in LA
only because it's by the costume shop I
was like I want to go in there I'm
trying I'm trying to eat like better
maybe I'll just have a steak and
whatever and the kid wouldn't shut up
and that I nice it was first was not
that nice it's very old and historic but
he's like this is the type of place that
like my parents would go to once a year
and my grandfather would take me you
know place like there and I'm like we
get it you're trash week how much do you
want to beat this drum your garbage what
is this what is this where people have
absolutely no sense of yeah it's a
restaurant where they serve steak we get
it you've had a horrible life I don't
know what you want me to tell you it's
uncomfortable it's not cute you gotta be
really hot if you're selling that you're
a trash bag you gotta be so [ __ ] hot
to sell that just simple like I don't
know about all these fancy places I
don't know about all these fancy
restaurant you gotta be just [ __ ] like
when people look at you they all want to
[ __ ] you if you sell that otherwise act
like you've been here before
act like you've been to a Steakhouse
before okay enough
nobody's nobody I don't know what mark
of value you think you have
because you you've done nothing and
you've been around people that have
never done anything I have never been to
a place like this this is a place we go
to this is the nicest meal I'll have all
year we'll then kill yourself I I don't
what is this addiction to your
unfortunate circumstances are we
supposed to applaud you then make
different choices dummy or don't maybe
you don't like it going out the nice
right it's fine you don't have to but
there's this pride now and having
nothing it's like this weird perverse
pride oh yeah see girl I got nothing
then get something or shut up and these
people are not systemic Lee
underprivileged people I'm not talking
to people that have been [ __ ] over I'm
not talking epstein victims here I'm
talking to [ __ ] class people who've
chosen to be comedians who think it's
funny that they don't have a dollar they
think it's great it's not cute it's not
fun and it's your fault you're lazy go
get something a job preferably we all
work shitty jobs you know it's just this
weird like loyalty to [ __ ] I still
get it well what are these people who
does that work on what does that work on
you go somewhere with somebody and
you're like this is a nicest place I've
ever been
what who's that work what am I supposed
to say well I feel great about this I
feel great I'm so happy that I took you
here no I'm embarrassed I'm with you now
I'm like like we shouldn't even be here
that we should have just stolen that
homeless guys food he's asleep you could
have eaten that in the back of the
Oberer enough I'm sick of that there's a
lot of people to do that [ __ ] by the way
there's a lot of people that
like seem to like they they think it's
like liked it like that their lack of
worldliness is something to be
celebrated they should be celebrated for
their ignorance of nice things no no you
should know you're not in the Peace
Corps
you haven't dedicated your life to help
like there's people like if somebody
said to me you know I haven't really
been to restaurants like this I've been
in Africa with a clean water project I'd
still look at them and go why but I
would at least get it I understand but
there's too many people out there that
confuse their laziness with with that
they've been denied something or that
they've been disadvantaged somehow and
that rich people that all rich people
just get rich because she Ana Clause
deposits money and their [ __ ] pillow
it's not true now a lot of rich people
get rich you know by murdering and
torturing raping maiming and Pibb but
that still stopped it I'm not saying
it's good but it's certainly not sitting
in a steak house and acting like I took
you to Taj Mahal or word Buckingham
[ __ ] palace I [ __ ] a lot
you know I mean let's not trash but a
young guy that I double recently came
and uh came to the room of Domino's I
was at on the road
younger guy good-looking guy comes in
with Domino's to the hotel I'm like he's
like ordered his pizza yesterday and I'm
hungry so I brought it up and he's like
a homeless guy kind of chased me because
he wanted the pizza and I'm like God
what he's like I'm gonna be so mad if
you don't have a microwave I'm like you
wanted to microwave Domino's pizza
before we [ __ ] that's what you wanted to
do you wanted to eat now after
absolutely but Waterhead will order
Domino's later I'm for that
it's mean you want to eat Domino's I
have to [ __ ] suck your dick while
you're eating Domino's it just doesn't
make any sense so I was like I'll get
you dinner and I got him dinner and he
got to eat what every he's not a trashy
person he's like a cultured kid he's a
drummer whatever he drums he's drumming
he's a drummer percussionist but he's
from the mountains
he's from the mountains he lives in the
mound he's like well there he's an
interesting guy
smart kiddies but every guy like that
that's very thin every thin guy with a
very big dick from a rural area or a
suburban area but let's you know not not
Beverly Hills let's just say it's you
know that type of guy for whatever
reason loves fettuccine alfredo they all
love fettuccine alfredo
it is like the white trash dish for
skinny guys with big dicks they love
eating fettuccine alfredo now most of my
audience is male and let's keep it that
way but there are females out there that
are probably it's a joke
but there are females out there that
understand what I'm saying that have
gone out with a skinny guy with a big
dick and he gets fettuccine afraid I now
they did not have fettuccine alfredo on
the adult menu with this restaurant they
only had it on the child menu so I had
to order two child portions for this guy
to make one portion of fettuccine
alfredo for him you know it is what it
is but again you know I'm not saying
that everybody has to like nice things
or nice restaurants or whatever okay
when I went out to the steak house and
the person was just continually
referencing that they had never been to
a place like this before and the day
were so impressed and I was just like if
you act like you deserve nothing you'll
get nothing you know and then you start
realizing oh this [ __ ] shouldn't be
here this person should be a
jack-in-the-box or some other horror you
know it's not far as you get older it's
not cute and it's not fun to have been
nowhere people that don't travel that
don't go anywhere that don't know
anything that have no other perspectives
what what is the point I was just down
in Hoover Alabama okay huntsville
alabama performing i performed at a
place called the stardome say legendary
comedy club because it's rough it is a
rough one many comics have had a tough
time there I had a tough time there it
was a beast of a room it's like elderly
black people and then white evangelicals
from the backwoods of Alabama I used to
do all black rooms I like black rooms
this was not as much a black room this
is a country room
be good it was like a lot of crowd work
a lot of riffing off the top but you
know I'm making fun of brunch in Alabama
they don't have [ __ ] brunch they
don't have it they do not have brunch
they have ten buffets they do not have
brunch doesn't exist so the frame of
reference on some of the jokes doesn't
really work I'm talking about TAC I'm
doing jokes about TAC moving into cities
guess where tech ain Hoover Alabama so
they're like it doesn't work it's not my
fault it's not their fault just frame a
rat you know it just is what it is but
it's like you travel you see different
[ __ ] I stay in the Courtyard Marriott
Courtyard married it's not just buying
shitty hotels and putting the married
name on them and you know hotels are
shitty when they have the popcorn
ceilings and when the the motel walls
are like that that sand paint you know
what I mean to hide the the structural
problems with the wall to hide how
[ __ ] up the wall is they have that
sand paint you know and it's like you
put your fingers over it and you feel
and when you're laying there you're
laying in the bed and the beds never
gray you're looking up at the ceiling
and the popcorn ceiling and you're
wondering how many hookers have laid in
that exact spot hoping that a John
didn't flip the [ __ ] out and choke them
to death you know
in Hoover Alabama how many [ __ ]
John's have [ __ ] some some dude some
[ __ ] guy from their church group
while their wife thinks they're out
taking a jog and some guys sucking them
off in a Courtyard Marriott how many
people's lives just the absolute horror
of people's lives how many and by the
way worse much worse than those two
images is me after a gig at the stardome
asking
why if it's called room service do I
have to go to the lobby and get it
that's the saddest image of them all me
going let me ask you a question
she goes what we don't have anyone to
run it up I go well you have you don't
you have you I got a beer for people to
check in honey honey honey no one's
checking in let's lock the doors and
let's call it a night everybody that's
here everyone that needs to be here is
here now
that's the road man and and it's it's
it's III thank everybody came out in
Huntsville Alabama I don't think I think
four people came out in Hoover Alabama
for four to seven fans of mine that
looked terrified
you know folks I thought a lot today
about I was on the beach I was in
Manhattan Beach I was swimming in the
Pacific Ocean and it was beautiful and I
was staring out I was looking at the
hills do not quite mountains but there
may be bare mountainous and I was just
kind of floating on my back and I was
looking up at the sky and it's just
beautiful the Pacific Ocean is beautiful
and I was looking around me at all this
natural beauty and I had a thought I
said to myself I said I wish I was in a
dark room online scrolling that's what I
realized
I said who the [ __ ] wants to waste their
goddamned time in the natural world the
natural world is a waste of time
everything that is not the Internet is
fake the virtual world is now the real
world it's actually the other way around
it's inverse
it's the upside down and stranger things
has become the right-side up nothing
valuable happens outside of a digital
community nothing I don't care about
your baby
I don't care about your father that died
I don't care about the bird you saw that
landed on your deck I don't care I don't
care about your kids first day school
unless I see it in a high-resolution
photo on your personal website that's
Brandon then I care that I'm with it if
I just happen upon it I don't give a
[ __ ] it doesn't matter to me okay
I want it organized I want to see it on
my time I'm not talking about social
media that's amateur hour I'm talking
about a website that you've built
yourself using wix.com a website that
where if you don't want to design it
their artificial design intelligence
which ad I will design it for you answer
a few simple [ __ ] questions can't you
do that can't you answer a few simple
[ __ ] questions and they'll design the
site for you and if you want to have
more input they have 500 stunning
templates that you can choose from to
create a website that's visually
appealing and functional okay because if
I can't go to a place to find out what
you're doing I don't want to see you in
real life I don't want to see you across
the table from me at a restaurant I
don't want to hear about I want you to
write a story about your mother's battle
with cancer and I want to read about it
while I'm eating cereal at two o'clock
in the morning I don't want to hear you
tell me about it while you have [ __ ]
fish breath do you understand human
interaction is a
Oh fer we don't need it soon sex dolls
are coming and we'll have will have some
type of breeding banks for new people we
don't need this constant we just need
people to [ __ ] put some [ __ ] time
into having a brand and put it on your
site oh you know my might you know what
happened to my cousin no I don't record
a video telling the story and embed it
in your Wix ID and I'll watch it I don't
want to see you in person I don't care
but if I'm online
I might go to your site I might buy
something post a link to something that
I can buy maybe I'll buy it maybe I'll
buy a mug from you but not if I see you
with one I want I want to do it on my
time my schedule Wix calm what's what do
we what are we doing here / what Tim
Dylan's going to hell you go yeah this
is the big thing you gotta go to Tim
Dylan's gonna hell calm look at the site
that was made using Wix Tim Dylan's
going to help calm scroll to the bottom
of the site click on the things very
cheap it's like 15 a month for a website
if you need a website
there's no cheaper than this that will
look professional telling you something
you need a website somebody need a gun
but some you need a website so if you
scroll to the bottom of Tim Dylan's
going to hell calm you click on the link
it'll give you $10 off any of their
premium plans 10% off 10% off any of
their premium plans okay so that you can
stop hiking stop cut the [ __ ] out get
online we're all online folks stay
online stay online there is no salvation
outside of this box that's it
TV's dead it's all over your family's
over you friends hate you get online
sell you
sell you seashells online see who will
buy him Irish women will use them as
ashtrays it's the best you can hope for
actually could hope for sell some
seashells online some fat Irish broad
will use it as an ashtray that's the
most you gonna get out of this life
some people gonna lie to you I'm not
gonna lie to you I'll tell you you ain't
you ain't getting much more than that
okay piggy
oink go to go to the site get the plan
don't [ __ ] around here if you don't buy
these plans you're gonna have to start
watching Stephen Colbert you want to do
that you want to watch Stephen Colbert
talk about Trump being orange for an
hour and to watch Pepsi drink Coke
here's Stephen Colbert good go do that
go do that go live in that nightmare go
watch Jimmy Fallon you know play pool
with Kermit watch Jimmy Fallon go to
[ __ ] uh go to Applebee's with Miss
Piggy and cardi B or whatever the hell
they're doing go watch that you want
that what that is your entertainment
maybe deserve that maybe deserve that
like some fat hog from Ohio okay is that
what you want a big fat slob from
Galveston Texas who's full of crawfish
mac and cheese you want that the life
you want no you don't go by the Wix plan
goodbye I mean these are big boys and
girls in Alabama these are big boys and
girls this is why I'm trying to lose
weight now because I don't understand
there's no end game I mean there was
this comedian Sophie Haig and it doesn't
show Edinboro she's a fat activist she
was one that threw a fit when Amy
Schumer had that movie the last movie
she did where she fell on her head I
forgot trainwreck no that was three
movies ago yeah I'm glad see this is
good whenever producers with it helps
the show uh I feel pretty it was a
this thing Amy did she fell on her head
this chick through a thick Jamie was not
fat enough for these women she's not fat
enough
she was [ __ ] Amy's not that fat so I get
it whatever and this chick does this
whole thing about being fat and I'm
watching some of it and she's like how I
learned to love my fat body and it's
like okay listen I'm not saying not to
love your body she's like I was eating a
burger and fries and these three
teenagers started to fill me and I'm
like okay well [ __ ] them they're pieces
of [ __ ]
nobody should film anybody you should
not abuse fat people you shouldn't do
any of that you should have [ __ ] beat
those three teenagers up you know with
her body mass I imagine that it would be
a pretty fair fight I think she could
probably really give them a run for
their money
um if not win handily but then it always
goes too far like it always goes too far
were you like hey I'm not less healthy
yes you are you can you feel less
healthy it's something that you can feel
you don't have to go to a doctor to find
out and look you see where it ends it's
like drugs
it ends up by 600-pound life that's the
end
those people are less healthy they can't
move they sit on pillows and then people
just feed them and somehow their gap
boyfriends and husbands into getting
laid these all right people talking
about these school shooters are kind of
decent-looking a lot of these shooters
I'm like I'd suck off anybody who's not
a mass shooting really in the last in
the last decade I would absolutely get
face-fucked why anyone who's done a mass
shooting in the last ten years what's
the problem
there'd be God how many of these mass
shooters
to feel guilty about jerking off I have
the idea of that I save him mass
shooting that I save like there's just
one of these creepy guys about to shoot
something up and then I meet him and I
just suck him so good that he just kills
me and then himself
and that's my dream and no one will know
that I the 20 people in a Walmart are
now safe just put a star on the wall
like the CIA Morial you'll never know my
name just a star on the wall I just you
know took some dick to the throat and
Hoover Alabama so that one guy won't go
out there now and shoot up and he just
goes [ __ ] what a great [ __ ] but now I
should just kill this guy in myself and
I'm like I don't have to I don't have to
do the Improv lab next week he goes nope
I got oh okay
and that's something that I've always
dreamed of and I'm gonna refresh my
email let's see if the guy from the
Booker from your mom's house has not
gotten back to me
I gotta think that's a bad sign now I
don't know I've been your producer of a
podcast you you you inhabit this world
now how do you how do you think this
person feels I'm gonna get a secret how
do you think this person feels about
what happened today
[ __ ] you were an hour late you didn't
respond for a whole hour
they were definitely checking your
Instagram and they saw the post for sure
and they thought oh [ __ ] this guy
absolutely [ __ ] this guy you get the
matches yeah yes Ben I believe that all
to be the case but as somebody who's a
do you do you say how do you do you
laugh about it do you say Tim is a funny
guy he's a funny guy and he's a wacky
guy do you maybe bring me in to berate
me and have drew berate me for being a
lawyer is that not nice I bet that would
be hilarious but I
but dr. Drew's probably a guy that his
time is very valuable so who knows who
did you see who they pulled in by the
way did they pull in somebody who I
didn't look I don't think they're
recording live cuz Jessa we just did one
and hers is gonna come out later on
I bet drew was pissed I bet he was mad
cuz he's sitting there he drove all the
way up to what Reseda it sent in traffic
to [ __ ] I can't control where people
go Ben okay I can't control where people
go I told you I had a [ __ ] emergency
my mother got out of her institution and
wound up in Manhattan Beach now I was
shocked when the people of my mother's
mental institution called me about your
mother is on the run again I said how
far did she get out back they said no
she's been sighted in Manhattan Beach by
the 10th Street Beach which is beautiful
you should go and try to find her in the
water and then when I got to the 10th
Street Beach they said I think she's at
captain trips fish market why don't you
go there and if she's not there at least
try the black and salmon and the lobster
roll and the macaroni salad which were
phenomenal
and then I got the captain trips and
they go she might be at the Trump golf
course so this [ __ ] I'm trying to get
her with a big match she's a big woman
now sit sit emerge and say god I am so
[ __ ] bad
I am so banned they're never had
me back I never had me back
I am done I am so done but that's what
it is man that's where you gotta get
good at lying you gotta get good at it
like when you go to a restaurant and
it's the nicest restaurant you've ever
been to you go oh yeah this reminds you
of a place I went to last week cuz I
hang I can hang you're the best [ __ ]
liar dude you've you're very talented
that's obvious
thank you but but today I [ __ ] up the
biggest talent is lying I've seen you
get out of so many [ __ ] situations so
many talk about that one in Long Island
remember that we went to go see that mob
Happel can I say the name of that guy I
guess I yeah okay any ocean right yeah
he was this guy that lived in my town
that The Sopranos is based on he ran a
family in New Jersey you know so Tim's
taking your getting a Netflix half-hour
before me by the way thanks a lot for no
offer my 50 minutes was good [ __ ] no
offer thanks a lot everybody over there
so we pull up to Vinny oceans house
which is Lobos art this year is kind of
believable
I hope it's within the realm of
believability because that shows about
as believable as me having an emergency
today so so we're driving across Long
Island and I'm I never worried about
being in the car with you even though
your license is proven unanswered many
times I know what I'm doing I just know
you have a life prepared if you get
pulled oh I haven't had a license in
five years I don't plan on getting one I
just ate and me have never seen eye to
eye it's not for me
like I parked you're doing was hard my
fingers you can't park it's not for me
these rules enough for me I don't
subscribe to this I don't care I don't
care
I'll leave I'll move I move out of this
thing he's like 'no no this is
alternate-side no today's not the day I
go oh today is the day today is
absolutely the day we park here cuz my
show is right there today's the day and
we parked and it's fine there was no
ticket boom I get bagged very rarely why
I hate to say it it's an unfair world I
look like a dad
like on the copy my kids are all dead so
go into that I'm sorry so we're driving
and and we pull into which you always
told me was down the street from your
childhood house but Tony Soprano's house
is down the street legit yeah with
Vinnie Ocean and you we pulled up looks
legit just like hunt David Chase had and
The Sopranos as soon as we pull in we
pull you pull and waits you far because
you were bad at using the shifting from
driving to reverse very bad if we go a
little too far and I pull my camera out
and then I start taking a picture and as
soon as I take a picture some dude in a
wife beater and shorts busts out the
front yeah what the [ __ ] y'all doing
were y'all doing no you're doing black
he's Italian oh we know how do you do
you're doing you're doing black you do
what's y'all doing let's secure what are
you doing
that was that that was that you doing
black so he comes up to my side of the
window I believe and I start looking at
my phone trying to think I'm like I
should just pretend I'm on a Google Maps
yeah you're no help but they said you
know you go I should have put my phone
you make it worse you like make it where
you look guilty you seem guilty and I
just looked at them and I like start
yelling at him like I don't know where
I'm going
look where am I going we gotta get we
gotta get out we have to get off the
island
let's go get off the island and now he's
confused clearly from Long Island but
I'm clearly from Long Island
I'm clearly I'm clearly from New York
how do I get I've never been here before
I'm familiar bama the guy sure but but
he was just thrown completely he was so
confused I think he do you were lying
but he was just like it you got to go
that way to get out okay and then it
took you like two minutes to like get it
into reverse
yeah get out of there but clearly a
member of the family
yeah probably you know I I've tried to
lie with care you know
today was a day when sometimes we caught
some time when I when I saw that email I
said I [ __ ] up
I [ __ ] up today I should have
remembered I forgot some times I'll
forget you ever just totally forget I
totally forgot the original date was
next week they moved it to Friday I
totally forgot
as soon as Christine said let's go to
the beach I was like oh that's fun we'll
go do that and I totally didn't think
mmm about it and I'm ashamed I'm ashamed
that I didn't but the Instagram story
was already up I was ready [ __ ] it's
kind of already [ __ ] you ever what were
you called me and you were just laughing
you just couldn't when the Instagram
shows up cuz it's an interesting thing
now that the stories are what do you do
you gotta be really good you almost go
do i do what do i do do i go full honest
single I just totally forgot I'm so
sorry and profusely apologize I could
have done that that might have been the
better move here too profusely apologize
hey I forgot although I think that's as
bad I think that's as bad yes oh that
seems like the best option here cuz
you're a [ __ ] nobody respects first of
all I wouldn't have this story I
wouldn't had a great laugh I don't
really give a [ __ ] either way [ __ ]
care like go on and get psychoanalyze by
[ __ ] dr. Drew for an hour
give us a [ __ ] I mean he would be nice
he'd be fun I do want to do Tom
Christina show I am upset you know but
here's the thing yes
you're right in this situation honesty
was probably the best policy but you
know it's like somebody there was that
quote maybe Willie Nelson then I forget
whose quota was the nightlife ain't the
right life but it's my life you know I
just said maybe if I just said I had an
emergency maybe the word emergency see
that you got to send that at 3 p.m.
mm-hmm you can't send it an hour later
even if at 4:08 I had sent that before I
put the story up I would have been okay
it was the hour later the emergency so
there you have it folks but that's what
the government is doing right now with
Epstein mm-hmm they don't care they
don't care that it doesn't make any
sense they don't care they always useful
idiots at Vox and all this but the Wall
Street Journal just wrote this whole
article about Lex Wesner Lex
Wester Leslie Wexner who's Jeffrey
Epstein's money guy he owns Victoria's
Secret and I love like there's a quote
in the Wall Street Journal article it's
like how could a man who sold blue jeans
to women and all these things to women
how could he end up financially
bankrolling some guy that ended up
taking advantage of women how could this
happen and he's trying to realize are
the people in the press complicit or are
they literal retards what is it are they
literal cuz anybody in that Alabama
audience would be like I don't know
maybe he's [ __ ] kids like any dumb
hick who you explained this story to
would very easily be like um maybe there
are [ __ ] kids together and that's why
he gave him that townhouse and all that
[ __ ] money
but these people that write these
articles went to like you Penn Yale and
Harvard and they don't seem to be able
to put it together that maybe the
relationship is a little pathological
it's a little nefarious they're like
Express
learned a blessing that was a whole
article let's learn the lesson about
trusting too much I swear to God get the
Wall Street Journal article up less
learned a lesson about you just can't
les his father told them Leslie tall
you're too trusting and kind that's what
I think what I meet billionaires I think
they're too trusting and kind that's my
first thought when I when I meet a
billionaire read read what this says
trusting Jeffrey Epstein taught a retail
legend a hard lesson
be careful whom you trust who is writing
this I mean literally Hillary Clinton
who is writing these articles maybe it
looks like you folks kids hmm
but they'll do people that don't look
like if like every elderly person looks
evil you know most elderly not all of
them I'm like Native Americans they
don't like elderly white guys it's so
easy to just point out Lee white guy be
like a demon but who is writing these or
like less wexter gave this [ __ ]
a seventy million dollar town house how
how nice you have to be how dumb and
nice you have to be you know less gave
him a town house and all this money for
an island and you know what Jeffrey did
with that money he bought all this
recording equipment and a whole bunch of
kids but kill him it do you know what he
did less gave him this big beautiful
townhouse in Manhattan and can you
imagine the Jeffrey use that to throw
child orgies man les was shocked and les
had no clue because as a billionaire you
don't have any resources you can't hire
private detectives ex-mossad CIA people
you can't hire the paramilitary teams to
follow this [ __ ] you have no clue
what's going on
you're just a billionaire a folksy old
billionaire who has no clue what's this
Internet who is writing these [ __ ]
articles
I'm really starting to be like because
if you would explain this to anyone at
Golden Corral he would said hey if you
would motion to somebody at Golden
Corral you know eating a yeast roll
wearing a hospital gown which is what
people wear there they wear hospital
gown and Hospital socks there because
it's the first step many of them go
right after they get out of and then
they go right back to the corrals right
back to the ER it's like a it's like a
circle if you had said to them you know
you know the pedophile that just got
caught with all that money some old guy
gave him all that money and wasn't this
guy wasn't a specific guy wasn't really
a genius I mean I think he dropped out
of college he got some math teacher job
at Dalton or whatever but he gave them
all that [ __ ] money everybody would
go oh oh yeah they're in cahoots
something's wrong I bet yeah I bet
but people were writing the Wall Street
Journal this ludes them and some other
people that read their [ __ ] go yeah poor
Leslie Wexner he just got taken for a
ride there was a show called The Music
Man a play that I was in when I was a
little kid were like this guy who like
barely knows how to teach music comes in
to different towns and like cons
everybody and that's what they're acting
like Epstein did he's just some con
artist some human trafficker con artists
it just shows up in a town and he
somehow gets the better of all these
billionaires that just don't have a clue
they don't have a clue Chris Matthews
that fat clump of Irish soda bread on
MSNBC who i watch occasionally cuz he
looks like my uncle he's a sputtering
like a good mother adorable Chris
Matthews suggested and I swear to God
that politicians are too poor to travel
and that they need people like Geoffrey
I've seen because he had a plane and
that's why they knew him he goes you
know these politicians they make you
know they have all these
friendships with these with these bad
characters cause a person's got a plane
in these politicians are making 150
grand a year and they just can't travel
so they I gotta get you to hahahaha
we're talking about Bill Clinton Chris
he didn't have the money to travel Chris
and the rest of these politicians
they're not broke you're full of [ __ ]
that's a lie
well these politicians because I know so
your your your angle is that they just
needed frequent flyer miles and that's
why they had to take this guy's plane
there's no other billionaires with
planes right just Jeff that's it you
tell me that none of these politicians
could I don't know get the CEO United on
the [ __ ] phone and get a few cops
what a [ __ ] are they going
but it's this nobody nobody wants so
much wondering I'm like are we watching
are we watching like full panic mode
right now where you have these agencies
like the CIA and the Mossad who've been
blackmail
people forever they've been using sexual
blackmail forever they've been using
assets like Jeffrey Epstein forever
they've been involved in bringing drugs
into the country forever they've been
involved in trafficking human
trafficking for a very long time they've
been involved in all of these things but
they seem to be I mean you got to
remember imagine this story without the
internet dude [ __ ] imagine this cuz
it was the Franklin scandal the Franklin
scandal was this exact story without the
internet they took a girl who told the
truth just like this Virginia Godfrey
did about obscene and they threw in
solitary confinement for two [ __ ]
years which is torture that's two grand
juries in Omaha we needed to cover up
the Franklin scandal because there was
no internet nobody gave a [ __ ] okay it
was not salacious it was not in the news
and what you ended up happening was was
just a massive cover-up
swept into the rug and they stacked
bodies carry Cara Dori who was the
private investigator who supposedly got
photos got got the blackmail photos that
incriminated people his plane ended up
breaking up with his eight-year-old son
small plane and that have blown up one
body William Colby CIA director at one
point who was looking into this also
ended up dead in his canoe and many many
other people this girl that was in
solitary confinement her brother ended
up dying they stacked bodies to prevent
this from coming out now with the
Internet we've already seen one body
you've already got apps teen they're
like well the New York Attorney General
said it's a suicide it's like oh well
all right
case closed they've already said
bones broken in the neck or more
consistent with strangulation they were
by the way not only should Alex Jones be
back on social media he should be given
ABC World News Tonight he should be he
should be given ABC World News Tonight I
don't know what to tell people I mean it
is what it is I'm sorry about the Sandy
Hook [ __ ] that's not good but let's stop
let's stop this the mainstream press
only exists to cover the tracks of these
people I don't know what else you need
you read these articles and you're like
how dumb are these people you can't be
that stupid
you can't have gone all these good
school I mean it's amazing I mean what I
meet people that are elites and I know a
few people have gone to schools like
that that are in circles like that and
they're stunningly ignorant they're
stunningly ignorant and that's why the
top 10 percent of these people that are
truly nefarious and our true operators
can really can really because they you
know they think the best of these people
and they are able to manipulate people
because a lot of the people that are
true elitism keeps you in a bubble you
don't you don't understand the way
things happen you don't understand a lot
of the things that people that were
sitting in the stardome in Hoover
Alabama understand because you are
you've been at the top of everything
your entire life and everything's come
very easy to you and you've never had to
look at anything from another angle and
you've never had to be deeply suspicious
and and you've never had to put things
together and your critical thinking
faculties are not as well-formed as
[ __ ] people that may have been
railroaded by the cops or a shady
prosecutor in a small [ __ ] town and
you're like well I've had the money in
the legal power to get away with
everything and you know I've always
gotten a fair shake and a fair deal talk
to black people they don't have a hard
time believing any of this because
they've been dealt with unfairly by the
system their entire life so they go yeah
this is what have you there's lying they
make [ __ ] up
doesn't matter but like these lily-white
[ __ ] that are writing these articles
I like I don't understand why you see
Series C cast that's weird that's weird
dumb [ __ ] very sad today about the
emergency that I had to prevented me
from going on the dr. Drew show it is
tragic development let's talk briefly
about the patreon page Ron is launched
it is here it is live it is real it is
actual what the patron is is a way for
people to support the show if there are
two levels or two tiers um but at the $5
left we didn't want to do a million
tears we know there's patrons with 75
tears you know hey if you donate this
will read your first name if you donate
this will read your full name stop stop
anybody want that anybody want to hear
that show where I'm like thanks Tommy
Oh Lachlan from Seaford New York if you
need to hear you name read on the
[ __ ] show go [ __ ] yourself
literally get a [ __ ] life you sick
[ __ ] this is an odd way to get into it
but we have to tears are we promising to
read names before I go oh no no no okay
we might we might have been in which
case I would have to walk that back a
little you know which I would say I
guess but we're not doing that [ __ ]
we're not doing that nobody wants that
I'm not doing that
I do you need that do you need that you
big baby
you need me to read your name every like
a baby like you go
that's that's me that's me cut it out um
we have two tiers at the $5 tier okay
and I'm talking to you YouTube you pigs
all your [ __ ] comments and I read
occasionally okay five dollars you get
one extra episode a week some of those
would be interviews some of them will be
episodes like this they'll be on patreon
you will also get all of the archives
from the show that I did with Ray Kampf
how many episodes I like a hundred forty
about a hundred four hundred and forty
audio archives interviews with Nick
Brian is the foremost expert on sex
trafficking as it results to the
political class russ Baker buncha Mark
Kelly ah T who wrote the great book
about the Russian mafia called the
Voorhis um you know Michele McPhee wrote
a book about the Boston bombing we have
John Q Yakub CIA agent who came on we
have a lot of comics like Bobby Kelly
Dan Soder Colin Quinn all of these are
in the archives and then a lot of great
episodes with me and Ray just a lot of
great episodes with me and Ray 100 and
how many about 140 140 audio archives
for you at five dollars a month mmm so
it's an extra episode every single week
of this show but we're gonna get some
great guests on and and a lot of the
episodes will be just out having fun and
then some of the episodes will have
guests also uh and the first type of
page that episode is crazy it's really
crazy we have a lot of fun we let loose
I let loose
I imagine Bill and Hillary the morning
of the epstein death and it's kind of
beautiful we might put out a highlight
from that a clip from that we should so
you have that now for $20 a month
because that's the way the world is now
it's the haves and have-nots
twenty dollars a month which is a lot
you're going to get everything that the
other people get which is the extra
episode a week the audio archives you're
also going to get longer videos of those
desk videos that I do you're going to
get the long versions of them and we're
also gonna start making special videos
just for patreon like we're gonna make
fun videos just for patreon you're also
going to get an email or you can
correspond with the show we will answer
you you can suggest topics you can
suggest interviews you can suggest
things we will get back to you we'll
talk to you you know you know it'll be
interactive oh you know we want you to
kind of help steer the show to
reasonable extent okay we know who some
of you're gonna want on we know I know
already I know what you want I know it's
something you're gonna want we know so I
know it's um if I paid twenty dollars
can David Duke come up now no David Duke
cannot come on if you paid twenty
dollars that's not enough money now I
will say this there was a thousand
dollar tier if you give me a grand will
I interview David Duke probably not get
it I'm not gonna agree with him I'll
probably I'll fire back at some of what
he says but for a G if you want to venmo
me a grand I'll probably interview David
Duke and I'll send it to you you know I
know that you know probably my agents
not gonna love that
there's thousand box grant no one's
doing that you know if you give me a
hundred thousand dollars
I'll have David Duke on every episode of
this show every single episode of this
show he'll be the co-host of the show if
you give me $100,000 you'd be the
co-host in this show
you know but that's yet listen if you
want to support the show we appreciate
it if you can't you don't have the money
keep telling people to listen keep
telling people to uh you know I'm gonna
I'm supposed to be on doctored reverse
you're never excited about that and just
look out for that one
hold your breath those are the tears $20
tear you really love the show you really
want to support as much as you can you
look at the longer version of the desk
videos you'll get you'll get I don't
know how many of you will probably do
two or three videos a month just for the
patreon will also do the regular videos
that we put a minute or two minutes out
those videos are much longer and there's
a lot of funny stuff that gets caught
there's a lot of funny stuff that gets
cut those are five minutes sketches and
even more and you'll get all of that
stuff and it's really funny stuff that
just doesn't make it it either can't go
on Instagram because of content or
because of time restrictions and you'll
get all that stuff and then hopefully
this builds to where we're doing our own
thing and we're producing things that
are actually funny and that you're gonna
watch those and you know this will be
you know people go oh this is what SNL
should be make it what SNL is you know
if we have the resources to do more than
[ __ ] we're gonna do as much of it as we
humanly possibly can and you guys help
us out it is what it is but I mean the
big corporate owned places are gonna
keep doing that safe [ __ ] and there's
nothing we can really do about that
other than do what we're doing and the
way to really throw a scare into those
corporate places again if you can't
donate money fine but it's just keep
telling people about the show keep
sharing those videos keep keep building
that because that's the only way these
people are gonna [ __ ] notice and
they're starting to notice they're
starting to notice that our engagement
is so much higher than the [ __ ] that
they're spending so much money to
produce people really like it people are
really into it if
you keep you know sharing that stuff
it'll be great you know I mean that's
what that's really the solution you know
is there anything else we should say
about the patreon patreon.com / the Tim
Dylan show that's how to find it that's
the URL right there and if you want to
find the archives when you're on the
patreon because they're gonna get buried
under all the stuff we're gonna post
just search archives I put a tag on all
of them that's archive or archives so
just search that and you can find the
whole list of every episode tim has done
with write and also if you want to hear
my episode with dr. drew you have to
really look I don't know when it's
coming out I feel bad I feel bad but
what can I do other than apologize other
than say in the future I'm gonna come up
with a better lie mm-hmm in the future
I'm gonna spin a yarn that makes
everything make sense
you know nothing worse than an
experienced liar when you strike out
it's nothing worse very sad you know you
know we're living in a time right now
where
to be sane in this climate is the surest
way to go crazy like that's really what
you start to realize is that by design
is that happenstance she's laying
Maxwell's eating in and out
reading spy novels Jeffrey Epstein in
protective custody kills himself before
he's about to testify they want you to
know that they don't care that there's
nothing that they can't do they will
never get caught they'll never be found
out this has been going on a lot long I
don't want a black pill everybody I
don't want people to be upset because
there is certainly there are options you
know and there are different ways
history can go and we've seen that but
right now you're you're you're seeing
how much they can [ __ ] you in your face
they're [ __ ] you in your face and no
one I mean people are upset about it but
the level of outrage is nowhere near
what it should be um and I think that
what this is like a little stress task
to it I mean they had to do it so it's
not like a stress test in the sense that
there was another option they had to do
this especially if this this this is a
billion bit multi billion dollar a year
industry human trafficking
all these rich fox need to know that
it's never getting now we're never
getting caught you know don't worry
about it it's never get now will never
happen
CIA Mossad they're they they they they
that's why like you know you can think
whatever you want a bit immigration or I
think you need it but you can't have
open borders there's got to be a policy
there's got to be a system which makes
me to some people a card-carrying SS
member and to other people it's not
nearly conservative enough because we
shouldn't have any immigrants oh I want
I want to do every job do you but my
favorite I mean Ray used to laugh about
this you know you know the people that
really against immigration they would
always say this which I love this is my
favorite other than pretend to care
about blacks which was hilarious
remember that all the conservatives were
like well then how a black people
getting at work it's like oh that's rich
that's really that your that's that's
the angle uh my favorite saying the of
the pro-immigration crowd was this they
go we're a nation of laws we're a nation
of laws nope nope no we're not no we're
not we're not we have laws sure you know
we're not a nation of laws that's insane
we're a nation of some people being
above the law and then other people
covering up and covering the tracks for
those people we're not a nation of laws
those laws aren't apply evenly and to
think that they are you have to be so
ignorant of history it's kind of
hilarious we're a nation of laws if you
don't if you
don't have the law on your side you know
everything's by the book here is it is
it
Jeffery Epstein's dead just laying
Maxwell's eatin animal style fries why
isn't this [ __ ] in cuffs
is it cuz we're a nation of laws is that
what it is how long have we done hour
and a half yeah oh god it's too long how
do the ads it's gonna be so [ __ ] long
company over here Tim de la comédie calm
please come to see me at good night's
comedy club in Raleigh which is coming
up August 22nd to the 24th I'm excited
to be there it's a great club stress
factory in New Jersey September 5th
through the 7th go bananas in Cincinnati
later that month please buy tickets tag
your friends in the social media post
tell them they should go the schedules
that I put up every week in LA or on
Instagram usually for my spots at the
improv of the Comedy Store if you want
to come out locally I'm gonna do some
headlining stuff in New York City the
fall I'm gonna run some time that I have
there at the stand comedy club and
restaurant I'm gonna come back probably
in October to do a half hour a new half
hour material there if not maybe a
little more in 45 minutes we'll see
we'll do a headlining set there might do
a lot of podcast there as well so and
I'm also I'm going to do my tour bus
show one final time for the New York
Comedy Festival this year in November
where I take a double-decker tour bus to
New York City all these wealthy areas
pass Jeffery Epstein's house and we talk
about all of the fun stuff like you know
all the stuff all the good stuff you
know you don't really hear on any other
tour all these fun people and how
they've made their money
poisoning rivers you know you know best
case so that's
about an hour an hour and 15 minute hour
and 20 minute show on the top of an open
double-decker tour bus we're gonna do
about five of them this is the last time
I'm gonna be doing that I started it in
I've done it every year I've done it
three years in a row this will be the
fourth year and kind of the final year
we were probably gonna tape it maybe
it'll become something maybe I'll sell
it as a special maybe not but it's the
last year that I'm gonna do that I love
doing it but it's time to retire it but
it is one of the funnest coolest
craziest things that I do and it's
something that you know it's an
experience that you can't really get
anywhere else
you know I might do it in LA I've always
wanted to do it in LA it works much
better in New York just the way the city
is set up and structured it's much
better so if you want to get tickets to
that Tim Dylan comedy that Tom color Tim
Dylan comedy dot-com you can sign up
there's an email list and we email you
24 hours before the tickets go on sale
the general public now obviously it's
[ __ ] August you got a while to go but
if you email that if you if you sign up
for that email list we shoot you out an
email 24 hours before tickets go on sale
to the general public you can you're
pretty much guaranteed to get tickets if
you act quickly if you check your email
check out three days later but because
you know it's 50 seats or 60 seats on
each bus it's not a lot of seeds
probably like 55 seats and I do five of
them no this is not a ton of people that
are gonna get to see this we're talking
in the low hundreds of people that are
kind they always sell out and people
really enjoy them and it's just a lot of
fun so that is something that'll be
happening to will hit you with more
details and look out for my episode that
I did today with dr. drew dr. drew after
dark was really fun I enjoyed it it was
great I think you enjoyed it too and
when that comes out I'll let you know
about it we'll post it on social media
thanks
much